[Music]
everybody vote today to JoVE vote you
vote I didn't vote you don't have your
little sticker on TV all right
stickers I'm wearing Milan my bare chest
right now oh you beat me I was gonna say
yes I'm wearing mine no it's I know that
the campaigns are finally over and we
don't know what's happened yet but
candidates finally get a chance to relax
today I don't if you heard this
President Obama played a game of pickup
basketball yeah Obama said listen I'm
beating a white guy at something today
[Applause]
yes aid you'll see the Obama rally the
big Obama rally yesterday yesterday at
an Obama rally jay-z appeared and he
altered some lyrics and he's saying I
got 99 problems but am it 8 1 well that
settles it Mitt Romney is never gonna
listen to jay-z again he's through with
jay-z yet I'm sorry mr. Z I can't listen
to you today MIT and Ann Romney cast
votes near their home in Massachusetts
yeah then they cast votes near their
homes in Virginia Ohio and Florida they
flew to the Caymans and cast impose
their Luxenberg President did a lot of
last minute interviews I think he did
what do you do like 15 interviews
yesterday and he said a lot of crazy
stuff yesterday President Obama said his
weakness is nachos
then his advisors told him relax you've
already got the Hispanic vote 7-eleven
has weighed in yeah you know this well
7-eleven at this moment 7-eleven
presidential polling contest has
President Obama winning re-election
that's according to 7-eleven yeah
however those results are being hotly
disputed by polling experts at Outback
Steakhouse so hang on and then we have
to hear from Long John Silver's yes
Barbies Arby's has fight in we're
supposed to it we're supposed to at the
7-eleven voter who also will eat like
anything in a tube on a roller and that
got you know like the taco tube where
all those hot dog things never mind just
go
I like any show that starts with never
mind
really never mind just go do that thing
you do hi I'm sorry I led you all over
here turn the other camera on some kooky
propositions here in California yeah
today voters in California voted on
whether actors in porn films have to
wear condoms yeah
I'm sorry ladies and gentlemen but I
thought our founding fathers decided
this 200 years ago Jefferson was up all
night figuring it out said anyone
appearing in a saucy woodcut shall wear
no Rams bladder
what's that pornography at the time I
saw see what I would cut oh very nice